so raise your hand if you've seen
somebody in your city standing on the
corner holding the sign like this I
think we all have if you're being honest
at least one time have you wondered if
they mean it if we offered them the job
would they really take it and what would
that job mean to them in their lives
well this is a story about what happened
in my city when we decided to find out
when we decided to think differently
about panhandling and lift people up
through the dignity of work we call it
there's a better way we call it there's
a better way because I believe there's a
better way to get the money you need
than panhandling on the corner I believe
there's a better way to help your
brothers and sisters in need than
handing a few dollars out the car window
we know there's dignity and work we also
know that people are much more likely to
invest in themselves if they believe
that their community is willing to
invest in them first and because we're
all wired to be kind and compassionate
it always feels good to hand a couple of
dollars to someone that is in need but
if you talk to panhandlers many of them
will tell you that you're a few dollars
don't necessarily go towards feeding the
body they go towards feeding an
addiction there's a better way my name
is Richard Berry and I have one of the
best jobs in the world I get to be the
mayor of a great American city
Albuquerque New Mexico and that was at
lunch on July 17th 2015 in my great
American city then I'll my way back to
City Hall I saw this gentleman standing
on a corner and as you can see he's
holding a sign and his sign says he
wants a job but if you look closer at
the picture you'll see he's standing
underneath the blue sign and that sign
says if you need help if you need food
or shelter or you would like to donate
please call three one
one our community service number so why
is this guy standing under knife Neath
my side with his sign well we wondered
if anybody would call that three one one
sign is it turns out they did eleven
thousand times people called I put those
up at about thirty intersections and we
did connect them with food and shelter
and services but yet he's still standing
under my sign with a sign that says he
wants a job it's simple he wants a job
so I decided to do something rare in
government I decided to make the
solution simpler rather than more
complicated I went back to my office I
gather my staff around and I said we're
going to take this man at his work and
others like him the man says he wants a
job we're going to give him a job and
we're going to make our city an even
better place in the meantime you see
Albuquerque is a beautiful place we're a
mile high the Sandia Mountains on the
east the Rio Grande runs through the
center of our city with the home of the
Albuquerque International Balloon Fiesta
on the day like today you could
literally ski this morning in golf this
afternoon but there's always something
to do always weeds to pole litter to
pick up so if you're going to have an
initiative like this in your city you
have to ask yourself two questions first
one is is there anything left to do in
your city then if the answer is no would
you please give me your mayor's phone
number because I need some advice but
the second question you have to ask is
this are your solutions to panhandling
working if you're like Albuquerque and
you're taking the punitive approach like
we used to handing out tickets to
panhandlers or those who give them money
I'm going to suggest that your solutions
aren't working and I know you're not
getting to the root of the problem in
your city so if you have something to do
you need people that need something to
do there's a better way and the good
news is it's not that complicated this
is a 2006 Dodge van it was in my motor
pool not doing anything we put some new
tires on it wrapped it with the logo
this van now goes out to street corners
where our panhandlers are we go to them
we stop the van we get out we ask them
if they would like a day's work rather
than panhandling for the day
and if you wondered if they really mean
it it takes us about an hour to fill
this van up in the morning because
almost everybody we asked takes a job
for the day but you need more than just
a van you need a super fantastic human
being to drive that van and my super
fantastic human being his name is will
this is him in the yellow vest will
works at our local nonprofit partner he
works with the homeless everyday the
panhandlers trust him he believes in
them he hustles I like to say where
there's a will there's a way
so if you're going to do the better way
campaign in your city you need to find
yourself a will because he's really one
of the keys to making this successful in
the City of Albuquerque you also need a
great nonprofit partner in ours the st.
Martin's hospitality center they've been
in our community for over 30 years
they provide counseling food shelter and
if they don't provide it they know
somebody in our city to desk but they do
something much more for me as the mayor
they provide agility you see it takes me
two weeks maybe two months sometimes two
on board an employee with the City of
Albuquerque so you could imagine my old
Dodge van my super fantastic human being
will a great local non-profit partner
they drive to the corner there's a
panhandler they say would you like to
work for the day the paint handler says
yes
when will says great I'll be back in six
weeks to pick you up it wouldn't work
it's really important that we have that
agility in our program and they do the
paperwork they do the insurance they do
all of the other forms that I can't do
quickly we pay our pan handlers $9 an
hour we feed them once at the job site
at the end of the day our old Dodge van
takes them right back to Saint Martins
and they get connected with counseling
services so far with the pilot program
in a couple days a week in a fantastic
human being in the Dodge van we've
cleaned up 400 city blocks in the City
of Albuquerque we've picked up over one
hundred and seventeen thousand pounds of
trash weeds and litter and I don't know
if you've ever waited tumbleweed but
they don't weigh much
you can imagine the volume of material
that we've picked up so my city has
6,000 employees and none better than my
solid waste department we send our
trucks out at the end of the day they
help the pan handlers put it into the
truck the material that they picked up
during the day and we take it to the
landfill I'm lucky that I have city
employees that are willing to work side
by side with our panhandlers they're
lifting up our city while lifting up
their lives and like anything else
listen it takes resources but the good
news is it doesn't take much
we started with an old van a super
fantastic human being a great local
nonprofit in $50,000 but we also had to
have Community Trust as fortunately we
had built that up in years prior to a
better way we have a program called
Albuquerque heading home a housing first
model where we housed the chronically
homeless and when I told my community we
wanted to do that differently I said
there's a smart way to do the right
thing we have now how six hundred and
fifty chronically homeless medically
vulnerable frankly most likely to die on
the streets in our city we commissioned
our University they studied it we can
tell the taxpayers we can save you
thirty one point six percent over the
cost of leaving someone to struggle for
survival on the streets we've now saved
over five million dollars while housing
six hundred and fifty people so we had
that community trust but we had to have
a little bit more of an honest
conversation also as a community because
we had to get people to understand that
when he handles five dollars out the
window they might actually be minimizing
their opportunity to help the person in
need and here's why that five dollars
might go to buy some fast food today a
lot of times it goes to buying drugs and
alcohol that same five dollars if you
gave it to one of our shelters could
feed seven people today and if you gave
it to one of our local food banks for
food pantries we could actually feed 20
people with that money
people ask well Albuquerque's six
hundred thousand people million Metro
this wouldn't work in our city we're too
big or too small I disagree if you have
one panhandler in one city block you
could do this if you live in the city of
eight and a half million people you can
do this
it doesn't matter what you do it's not
the work that you do it's the dignity of
the work you could do anything so I
think any city could do this and people
say to me mayor that's just a little too
simple you know it can't it can't work
that way but I'll tell you what friends
when you go to a street corner and you
engage with the panhandler with dignity
and respect maybe for the first time in
years maybe in their life and you tell
them that you believe in them and that
this is their city as much as it's your
city and you actually need their help to
make our place better and then you
understand that this isn't the answer to
all their problems but at least it's a
start an amazing thing happens and when
they get out on the jobsite they start
working together you start seeing
amazing things happen they see teamwork
they see the fact that they can make a
difference at the end of the day when
they get back to seeing Martin to that
old Dodge van they're much more likely
to sign up for whatever services they
need substance abuse mental health
counseling you name it so far with our
pilot program we've offered about 1700
days of day work we've connected 216
people to permanent employment
opportunities 20 people actually
qualified for our housing housing first
model heading home and they've been
housed and over 150 people have been
connected to mental health substance
abuse services through there's a better
way but this is me just two weeks ago at
st. Martin's doing our point-in-time
survey that we do every two years and
I'm interviewing not a gentleman who's
homeless like we do getting his
information figuring out where he got
where he's from how he got there what we
can do to help him and he knows he's
holding the same sign that the guy was
holding in 2015 same sign and walked out
with here today so you have to ask
yourself is he really making a
difference absolutely making a
difference Albuquerque is now one of the
national leaders in combatting some of
the most stubborn and persistent social
issues that we have combined with
Albuquerque heading home the better way
program Albuquerque has reduced
unsheltered homelessness in our city by
80 percent last year since I took over
as mayor we've been able to reduce the
chronic homeless population in our city
by 40
percent and by HUDs definition we've
gotten to functional zero which means
we've literally ended better it's
homelessness in the City of Albuquerque
by being intentional so I'm happy to
report that other cities are hearing
about this other mayor's are calling us
Chicago Seattle Denver Dallas are now
starting to implement programs where
they bring the dignity of work to the
equation and I can't wait to learn from
them
I can't wait to see what their
experiment looks like what their pilot
project looks like so we can start
taking a collective approach nationally
to the dignity of work and I want to
commend them the mayors their
communities their nonprofits for the
work that they're doing so who's next
are you in your city ready to step up
are you ready to think differently about
these persistent social issues are you
ready to lift people up in your
community through the dignity of work
and make your city profoundly better in
many ways well if you are my friends I
promise you there is a better way thank
you
[Applause]